a warning that indemand rasheed's report
contains some flashing images
[Music]
many of the greats have blessed this
iconic venue with their talent
from the arctic monkeys to pulp from the
kaiser chiefs to coldplay the lead mill
in sheffield has given so much
[Music]
but its future is now under threat
the management here announced they're
being evicted and forced to close the
venue prompting a wave of dismay across
the industry
the kaiser chiefs saying it would be a
huge loss to the whole uk music scene
whilst the lead singer of the charlatans
urged let's do all we can to stop the
lead mill from closing
this once derelict flour mill was turned
into a world-renowned music venue in the
80s as a result of the lack of cultural
facilities in sheffield it was never
meant to be about money but a place to
help young musicians
more than 40 years on and clearly
a lot has changed
but the brixton-based owners say the
venue is going nowhere instead a
multi-million pound refurbishment and
have promised to preserve the lead mills
important history
i totally get that everybody is very
upset and worried about the future of
the lead mill but i would just like to
say again
um the lead mill won't be closing we're
retaining it we are a music venue
operator
venues need to change they need to
organically change and also facilities
in them need to change i mean the
artists some of the artists i've talked
to have talked about the fact that the
led models are amazing space but it
needs improvement and actually that's
what we do
in sheffield though they're not
convinced beach coma played here just
three weeks ago and are worried for the
future of this city's grassroots music
there's much bigger venues in sheffield
outside in the arena but the history
of this place you know it's such an
iconic venue all the names that are
passed through
um they would never have made it i think
the music scene in sheffield takes the
lead from the lead mill
so um yeah and all of its history behind
it it would it would fall away if it if
it ever closed down there's no doubt
this iconic venue's future has been
thrown into question
its potential shutdown is devastating
for many
but even if it does remain open keeping
its heritage is crucial for this city
and the musical world in zaman rashid
sky news sheffield